[Music]
you you're Ned Stark's bastard aren't
you did I offend you sorry technically
speaking a bastard is is just any child
born out of wedlock who did it stuck is
my father
ladies Stark is not your mother making
you a bastard
medieval societies including Westeros
tended to be more religious than our
modern society more superstitious in
some ways they do nothing about genetics
or DNA but they have their own version
of it which is blood blood will tell
just a bastard the bastard of Robert of
the house Baratheon the grand maker of
bastards in the Seven Kingdoms is Robert
Baratheon we see about four of them
being murdered in the opening episode of
season two when Joffrey sends forth his
people to find them the one who gets
away from that slaughter of the
innocents of course is injury who is one
of Roberts older bastards and Gendry
looks very much like the young Robert
something in Ned recognizes the minute
he lays eyes on Gendry find anything
King Robert's bastard soon Westeros of
course is a very strong class structure
the small folk as they're called they
probably produced just as many pastors
if not more as the noble classes but
they don't have any surnames and here we
have Bronn son of you wouldn't know it
the noble houses do have their names and
when they produce bastards they can't
have his father's name so they give him
a bastard name very simple declarative
names that basically tell you this
person has noble blood in them but their
bastard boy huh Robert
and it differs from region to region in
the north you have snow in the Vale of
Arryn it's stone in the Riverlands it's
rivers and the western lands it's Hill
Iron Islands it's pike in the reach it's
flowers in the area around King's
Landing the name waters has been used in
the Stormlands at storm and in Dorne
it's sand I don't believe you have met
Ellaria this is the Lord hand Tywin
Lannister and Cersei Lannister the Queen
Regent milady can't say I've ever met a
sand before Dorne is a very different
culture from the rest of Westeros it's
more hedonistic approach to life they
take in many ways a more relaxed
approach to life bastards are born of
passion aren't they we don't despise
them in Dorne no torrent of you the
Dornish have different customs quite a
few different customs one of which is
just that bastards aren't looked down
upon in the way that they are and the
other six kingdoms people everywhere
have their differences in some places
the highborn frown upon those of low
birth you're a bastard you're nothing
here
whereas in Dorne we have loads of
bastards I'm surrounded by them them up
that's my family I'm one I have 10,000
brothers and sisters and I'm not quite
sure what to call you Ilario works for
everyone knows all arias and might be a
bastard but it's quite permissible for
her to be the mother of a Prince's
babies and no one really thinks twice
about this what do you do with a bastard
child every house does something
different some will raise the bastard
child as a member to family but the
bastard child has no inheritance rights
a bastard boy with nothing to inherit
off to join the Ancient Order of the
Nights Watch lotta bastards do gravitate
to the wall Jon Snow it's not the only
one up there by any means well they were
always welcome on the wall no bastard
was ever refused to see that bastards
can rise their to officers and command
some of you bear the names of proud
houses others only bastard names or no
names that's all
more egalitarian society not completely
by any means it still tends to favor the
sons of boards and the sons of Great
Houses
Lord snow here grew up in the castle
spitting down on the likes of you
you have John snow of course it was
probably the most famous bastard in the
in the story he's right up front the the
bastard of Winterfell I think John did
have a choice to join us what you know
he actively chose he wants the Nights
Watch to emulate his uncle Benjen and
eventually I think in his head to lead
he wants to lead them when John first
came to Castle black he was maybe a
little bit spoiled he was a tough kid
and he was a kid we'd never back down
from the flight but at the same time he
grew up in a castle he grew up with very
high-class people and even if he was a
bastard himself his best friend was Robb
Stark and he was raised by Ned Stark and
he ended up thriving at Castle black and
becoming a leader for the first time
none of that would have come to pass and
none of that would have been the way it
was if Jon Snow felt that he belonged in
Winterfell Jon Snow's second-class
citizenship and Ramsay Snow's
second-class citizenship I mean these
are major kind of driving forces in the
story father welcome home
Walda this is Ramsay snow my bastard
Ramsay snow is a bastard son of Roose
Bolton Ramsay grew up knowing he was a
Lords son but completely disinherited
not part of the castle life just living
with his mother but when Roose Bolton
the son died he was all the Roose had
left so there's a tremendous amount of
anger and resentment Ramsay has a
problematic relationship with his father
I think psychopaths off and have
problematic relationships with their
father my mother taught me not both
stones and cripples but my father told
me
well they had but his main goal in his
life would be to be given the
acknowledgment respect of his father
that he's been denied as a bastard his
entire life he hates being busted and he
wants to be legitimate and he wants to
kind of impress his father that's the
only thing I think that he wants more
than just inflicting pain on people the
relationship of doing roots and Ramsay
is in some ways adore
counterpoint to the relation between Ned
Stark and John Snow in both cases a
noble father with a bastard son John and
Ramsay are literally the opposite to
each other you know John's very noble
and honorable and none of those things
Roose himself is a cold and calculating
and a dispassionate man I place a far
too much trust in you what your
treatment of the bastard son is is very
different
Ned keeps job snow at Winterfell and
he's raised with Robb and brand he's
thrilled practical purposes he's one of
Ned's sons you are a stuck you might not
have my name behind my blood
Ramsay gets nothing from Roose the
flayed man is on our balance my bonus
not yours you're not a boat in your snow
there's also some analogs here to the
Tyrion Tywin relationship the hell do
you know about being a busted old
wharves are bastards in their father's
eyes let me give you some advice bastard
never forget what you are the rest of
the world or not wear it like armor and
it can never be used to hurt you
you